und nun begrüße ich Sahra Wagenknecht
bei mir im Studio herzlich willkommen
Frau wagknecht sie sind derzeit die
beliebteste Politikerin des Landes
Politikerin laut einer neuen Umfrage und
sie könnten für einen politisches Beben
sorgen
sollten Sie eine eigene Partei gründen
diese Frau hat die Macht gleich zwei
Parteien zu erschüttern ihre Partei Die
Linke und die AFD experten sagen eine
Wagenknecht Partei würde die Linke
Spalten und die AFD halbieren Sarah
Wagenknecht im Höhenflug sie ist nach
inserumfrage für Bild auf Platz 2 der
Politiker Hitparade nur Markus Söder ist
beliebter besonders beim Wähler links
und zu rechts außen kommt Wagenknecht
gut an 60% der linken Wähler und 63% der
AFD Wähler könnten sich die Wahl einer
Wagenknecht Partei vorstellen warum
kommt eine weit links stehende
Politikerin bei den Anhängern einer
rechtsaußenpartei so gut an
ja Frau Wagenknecht wie erklären Sie
sich dieses Ergebnis naja es zeigt
eigentlich nur wer heute in Deutschland
alles AFD will das sind ganz viele ganz
normale Menschen die einfach entsetzt
sind über die Regierungspolitik die
früher wahrscheinlich SPD gewählt haben
vielleicht auch linke gewählt haben und
die jetzt das Schreiben mir auch viele
einfach nicht mehr wissen was sie wählen
wollen wählen sollen weil sie sich von
keiner Partei mehr vertreten fühlen und
das ist ja ein Problem man es gibt ja
auch noch ein sehr großen Teil von der
Bevölkerung die gehen gar nicht mehr zur
Wahl also das ist ja nicht nur dass man
AFD aus Wut wählt sondern teilweise
fühlt man sich auch von allen Parteien
so im Stich gelassen dass man sagt man
geht gar nicht mehr hin und ich finde
das ist schon ein Problem über das
meines Erachtens alle Politiker
nachdenken sollten warum haben sie das
Vertrauen dieser Menschen sie sagen das
ist ein Problem also sehen sie es ja
auch als problematisch an dass diese
Menschen die AFD wählen nun könnten sie
wir haben es gerade gehört zwei Drittel
der afd-wähler würden es befürworten
wenn Sie eine eigen Partei gründen
würden das heißt sie könnten
möglicherweise zwei Drittel zu sich
ziehen wenn Sie eine eigene Partei
gründen würden würde sie sich sie das
nicht total reizen wer das nicht quasi
schon ja eine Aufgabe für Sie das zu tun
und die afd-summe zu schwächen
na primär ginge es ja darum also was ich
mir schon wünsche ist dass in
Deutschland eine Partei entsteht die die
Politik der Regierung verändern kann
also das muss ja das entscheidende sein
also ich finde dass die jetzige Ampel
eine wirklich katastrophale Politik
macht also ganz viele Menschen haben ja
die treibt die nackte Angst um ich meine
die kriegen Rechnungen die können sie
nicht bezahlen die Handwerker sehen dass
ihre Unternehmen kaputt gehen weil sie
einfach diese kosten ja nicht
weitergeben können Bäcker aber auch
viele andere kleine Mittelständler im
industriellen Bereich da sind 100.000
Arbeitsplätze in Gefahr ohne Not weil
die Ampel eine völlig unsinnige Politik
macht sie klemmt uns ab von billigen
Rohstoffen von billiger Energie ohne
Alternativen zu haben und da das möchte
ändern ja aber es ist halt nicht so
einfach eine Partei zu gründen das ist
nicht so einfach aber es wäre machbar
also ist das ein dass kein Dementi das
ist kein nicht Gründe keine eigene
Partei ach wissen Sie die Zukunft ist
offen und ich glaube unser Land
verändert sich zurzeit sehr sehr stark
und wenn man die Ampel nicht stoppt habe
ich große Sorgen in welchem
Verhältnissen wir in ein zwei Jahren
Aufwachen werden also ich meine die
Industrie ist der rückt ist das Rückgrat
unseres Wohlstands wenn das kaputt geht
dann bricht hier alles weg und deswegen
muss ich das verändern und es muss Druck
geben es muss mehr Druck geben auf diese
Regierung dass sie so nicht weitermachen
darf sprechen wir über ein Thema das uns
alle derzeit beschäftigt und zwar die
Energiekrise und zu der haben sie ja
auch eine sehr klare Meinung
die Energiepreise explodieren die
Menschen haben Angst vor ihrer
Abschlagszahlung und fürchten im kalten
zu sitzen unser Gast macht für die Krise
nicht Russland verantwortlich sondern
einen Wirtschaftskrieg den Deutschland
gegen russlandführer fordert
Verhandlungen mit Putin
[Musik]
das Verbrechen wie will unser Gast denn
die Energiekrise lösen
wie wollen sie die Energiekrise lösen ja
ich würde mir auch wünschen wir hätten
lauter
lupenreine Demokratien die eine
friedliche Außenpolitik machen bei denen
wir unsere Energie und unsere Rohstoffe
beziehen könnten aber das ist nicht der
Fall und ich meine ich finde diesen
Krieg in der Ukraine auch verbrecherisch
und ich finde man muss alles tun um ihn
zu beenden aber wir helfen der Ukraine
nicht wenn wir unser Land zerstören wenn
wir unsere Industrie zerstören wenn wir
die Menschen arm machen und so lange wir
keine Alternative haben solange wir
nicht woanders preiswert des Gas und Öl
bekommen finde ich dass wir es aus
Russland kaufen müssen das heißt aber
auch dass sie bereit sind mit einem
kriegsverhältnisverbrecher Handel zu
betreiben da wissen sie das ist doch
eine Doppelmoral wir treiben Handel mit
vielen Kriegsverbrechern Frau von der
Leyen war jetzt in Aserbaidschan also
bei Jan hat Armenien überfallen
militärisch abbrechen verhandeln wir
dann mit einem Kriegsverbrecher ist ja
egal was wir in anderen Ländern tun es
geht jetzt um diese Debatte und würden
wir das nicht wir fahren also Herr
Scholz fährt nach Saudi-Arabien
Saudi-Arabien führt in jedem Jemen einen
Krieg der schon 300.000 zivile Opfer
gekostet hat 80.000 Kinder sind
gestorben also es ist einfach unehrlich
und ehrlich gesagt gerade von den Grünen
es nervt mich diese verlogene
Doppelmoral dieses Heere Getue wir sind
die guten Menschen deswegen dürfen wir
nicht mit Russland verhandeln und dann
fährt er Habig in Nahost in eine
islamistische Diktatur und macht Tiefe
Bücklinge es ist die Welt ist nicht so
wie wir sie uns wünschen ich wünsche mir
auch dass wir mit keinem Diktator
verhandeln ich wünsche mir dass wir mit
keinem der Kriege verbrecherische Kriege
in gangsitz verhandeln aber wir brauchen
preiswerte Energie und wir haben zurzeit
keine anderen Möglichkeiten wenn die
Ampel eine andere Möglichkeit hätte wenn
Norwegen riesige Gasfelder jetzt
plötzlich erschließt und sagt okay wir
liefern uns euch preiswertes Gas ja dann
würde ich sagen unbedingt in Norwegen
kaufen und nicht mehr in Russland aber
es ist nicht so das heißt sie würden
sagen sie sehen keine andere Alternative
und würden deswegen mit Putin verhandeln
ich würde gerne einmal noch auf diesen
Einsatz eingehen den Sie gesagt haben
sie haben gesagt dass wir einen Krieg
eine Wirtschaftskrieg vom Zaun gebrochen
haben mit Russland sie wissen ja aber
dass das nicht so ist sie wissen dass
das keine Wahl war die wir einfach so
getroffen haben das war schon die Wissen
mal sie wissen aber das Putin der
Aggressor ist und das er angefangen hat
Krieg zu führen gegen die Ukraine und
gegen die demokratischen Werte und
trotzdem sagen Sie diesen Satz aber so
der Krieg ein Wirtschaftskrieg wurde vom
Zaun gebrochen wieso wieso sagen sie das
so ja weil es diese Zwangsläufigkeit
nicht geht Putin hat einen
verbrecherischen Angriffskrieg in der
Ukraine gestartet und dafür muss man ihn
verurteilen und man muss jetzt trotzdem
versuchen dass er irgendwie zu einem
Ende kommt das schaffen wir nicht wenn
wir immer mehr Waffen liefern aber das
ist das eine Thema aber auf diesen Krieg
wurde reagiert indem die EU riesige oder
der Westen insgesamt große
sanktionspakete beschlossen hat das ist
eine Strategie die vor allem von den
Amerikanern vorgeschlagen wurde und es
wurden ganz ganz viele russische
Produkte auf die Sanktionsliste gesetzt
eben auch Öl auch Gas auch vor allem
auch Kohle und viele viele andere
Produkte russland hat dann reagiert und
hat teilweise gesagt okay wenn ihr
unsere Gas in Zukunft nicht mehr wollt
dann stellen wir es gleich ab aber
begonnen hat diesen Wirtschaftskrieg die
EU das muss man ja festhalten und auf
andere Kriege haben wir nicht mit
solchen Sanktionen reagiert also es gibt
diese zwangshäufigkeit nicht trotzdem
frage ich wieso haben sie diese Worte so
gewählt weil sie doch ganz genau wissen
dass wir nicht einfach einen Krieg vom
Zaun gebrochen haben kann es sein dass
sie damit ihre Wähler ansprechen wollen
die ja scheinbar jetzt mittlerweile aus
von beiden Seiten kommen von links und
von rechts es geht ja nicht darum wen
man ansprechen will es geht ja um
Lösungen wir brauchen in Deutschland
dringend eine Lösung für das Problem
explodierender Energiekosten wir sehen
dass es so nicht weitergehen kann also
oder wollen wir wirklich sehenden Auges
100.000 Arbeitsplätze zerstören ich
meine der Präsident des DHK sagt wenn
wir so weiter machen sind wir in wenigen
Jahren um 30 Prozent ärmer und Russland
schadet es gar nicht das ist ja das
Absurde wir Schaden ja Putin nicht aber
auch wir wollen aber auch nicht dass die
Menschen in der Ukraine sterben ja aber
das erreichen wir nicht dass dieser
Krieg aufhört erreichen wir nicht mit
den Wirtschaftssanktionen die Putins
Staatskasse füllen also die machen ja
viel viele hohe Gewinne dadurch dass die
Preise so explodiert sind also selbst
wenn man gute Willen unterstellt und
unterstellt dass die Regierung
tatsächlich ursprünglich dachte wir
setzen damit Russland unter Druck jetzt
muss man doch sehen die
hauptgeschädigten der Sanktionen das ist
Deutschland das ist Europa die USA
profitiert aber auch Russland profitiert
also sollten wir das nicht fortsetzen
wir kommen glaube ich hier zu keiner
Einigkeit mehr an diesem Abend in diesem
Punkt lassen Sie uns über ein Thema
sprechen ab unabhängig von Krieg und
Energiekrise gab es diverse andere irre
Diskussionen im Jahr 2022
ob ihr zeitkracher Leila oder Winnetou
Filme ist so etwas heutzutage noch okay
in ihrem Buch die selbstgerechten
kritisiertwagenknecht Diskussionen über
sprechverbote rechnet mit der
burgbewegung ab die sogenannte
Identitätspolitik die Menschen entlang
Geschlecht oder Hautfarbe in Opfer und
Tätergruppen teilt hält sie für falsch
stellt sich damit gegen das Trendthema
der linken politischen Bewegung wie
sieht ein perfektes Wochenende für
unseren Gast aus zu Layla tanzen oder
Winnetou gucken
ja sie haben ein Buch über den ganzen
Vogue Wahnsinn geschrieben wir haben
vorhin ein Beitrag in der Sendung
gesehen im Rathaus in Stuttgart wurde
auf dem Männerklo ein tampon-automat
installiert mit der Begründung das ist
viele Menschen mit Monatsblutungen gäbe
die sich nicht als Frau identifizieren
würden was sagen sie dazu dass ich das
einfach diese ganze Debatte wirklich für
Schwachsinn halte und ehrlich gesagt als
ob wir jetzt keine anderen Probleme
hätten also das zeigt doch dass Leute
die solche Diskussionen fühlen irgendwie
weit weg von dem Leben normaler Menschen
sind also ich meine Familien treibt
jetzt um wie kommen sie mit ihrem Geld
über dem Monat und es waren ja die
Grünen die das eingebracht haben die
führen solche Diskussionen also ich
finde das absolut daneben und ich mich
nervt auch diese Attitüde wo sich
Politiker auch in anderen Fragen in
sprachfragen nicht als Vertreter der
Bevölkerung sondern sozusagen als
Erziehungsbeauftragte des Volkes
empfinden und den Leuten vorschreiben
wollen wie sie zu denken zu reden und zu
leben haben
ich finde das sehr daneben andere Themen
die uns beschäftigen ich zeige Ihnen
diese Bilder hier in
Mecklenburg-Vorpommern hat es in einer
Flüchtlingsunterkunft gebrannt Ukrainer
mussten aus den Flammen gerettet werden
zuvor wurde das Schild mit der
Unterkunft mit einem Hakenkreuz
beschmiert man geht von einem
politischen motivierten Anschlag aus
letzte Woche bei einer Demo in Leipzig
wurden Ukrainer massiv beschimpft unter
anderem mit rufen wie verpiss Dich wir
hatten lange eine Willkommenskultur hier
alle haben geholfen wir hatten einen
riesen Zusammenhalt und jetzt das kippt
die Stimmung in Deutschland ich glaube
nicht dass man sagen kann dass das
repräsentativ ist für die Stimmung in
Deutschland also ich finde das wirklich
abscheulich wenn Unterkünfte angezündet
werden und wenn Hakenkreuze dort gemalt
werden sieht man ja auch wo es herkommt
aber ich finde es auch ein Problem wenn
man immer mehr Menschen die jetzt
wirklich protestieren die mit solchen
Aktionen überhaupt nichts zu tun haben
und die die auch verurteilen die aber
jetzt auf die Straße gehen und sagen wir
wollen dass die Politik sich verändert
wenn die dann als rechts abgestempelt
werden weil das ist etwas ganz anderes
man macht dadurch die Rechten stark und
wenn man wirklich nicht will dass solche
Typen die solche Dinge solche Untaten
verüben dass sie immer mehr Einfluss
bekommen dann muss man etwas dafür tun
dass sich die soziale Lage nicht immer
weiter zuspitzt und dass wir nicht auf
eine solche wirtschaftliche Katastrophe
zu rollen also da sind wir bei dem Thema
von vorhin man muss etwas verändern an
der Politik der Ampel wenn die weiter so
unser Land zugrunde richten dann werden
die Rechten immer stärker und das
erschreckt mich und da habe ich Angst
davor vielen Dank für diese Analyse
dieser Bilder vielen Dank für Ihren
Besuch
[Musik]